spirit stallion of the Cimarron Kumaran
key spirit in some ways this is when a
dream works most adult films in that it
doesn't really have talking animals it
doesn't have a ton of singing animals
either but it also has a narration by
Matt Damon odd choice and a soundtrack
that mostly consists of a tee style
songs also weird choice does it all come
together oh he doesn't know the story
centers around the life of a horse in
the new West Native Americans are in the
process of fighting for their land
against the white man and one lone horse
is separated from his mother at his
group Confederate soldiers try to tame
the horse but this is an untamable
animal that is except for maybe a Native
American teenage boy who is also
captured by the army the two escaped and
tried to find their way back home along
their travels they come across many
dangers get separated reunited and
separated reunited comes across some
other interesting characters he's a
bunch of really pretty landscapes is
conflicted on who he is and where he
belongs all sorts of good stuff so like
I said before the most interesting
aspect about the film is that the
animals don't really talk except for
again a narration by Matt Damon but even
that's sort of toned down to just the
bare bones essentials really the
majority of the movie is just told
through the horses expressions and you
know what
kudos which is not to say I'm against
talking animals in movies but it's just
so often we see it and now here's a film
where the talking animals are not needed
and it still works most of the emotion
is communicated through the expressions
on the faces which on a horse is very
difficult to do but the anime errs do a
really decent job you want to know
what's going to happen to them you want
to get through their journey and this
creates a really good adventure good but
not great to the film's credit this is a
very hard movie to make great I mean it
has a lot of things against it with not
making the animals talk and focusing on
an animal that mostly has to be on all
fours most of the time so the fact that
this is a good movie at all I think is
actually pretty impressive
it's a tough flick to make interesting
and they don't shy away from the dark
stuff either I mean when times get
really rough they show how really rough
they get and when you really need to
enjoy the good side of nature and all
that has to
Furret really takes time to show that as
well the 80 style songs are either gonna
love or you're gonna hate I'll admit I
kind of enjoy them I don't know maybe I
just have a certain nostalgia for them
but I can see it really getting in the
way for other people too and maybe
that's what the film comes down to just
sort of personal taste if you really
like the Wild West and pretty shots of
canyons and mountains and the desert and
so forth this is probably your flick it
does seem very in tune with nature and
doesn't feel like it has to rush
anything I guess well I'm just not
really one for that Western sort of
world I think a movie has to try
especially hard to get me into this sort
of environment which is not to say it's
a bad environment it's a pretty
environment it's just not my favorite
and with all these other elements to
fight with like I said the horse is not
talking and so forth I'm amazed to get
my attention as much as it did so I'm
impressed with how they pulled this off
not one of my personal faves but I'm
glad I saw it it has pretty scenery good
character some great animation and the
maturity to know when to let the words
do the talking and when to let the
imagery do the talking if you got a
little extra time on your hands I
definitely say check it out
Under the Sun